[موسيقى]
من الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
الثقافيه السعوديه بانام نسائيه بامتياز
حدثنا اكثر عن المعرض نتجول في معك
اهلا وسهلا سهام تحيه طيب عليك ولجميع
مشاهدي صباح العربيه بالتاكيد اليوم اقف
في احدى المعارض الكبيره جدا التي تقدم
اعمالا فنيه مدهشه تقدم عدد من الاعمال
التي تصف ابسط الاشياء التي يمكن ان يقوم
بها الفنان هي تمثل مقوله السهله الممتعه
انه بابسط الاشياء التي يمكن ان يقوم بها
الفنان في التطريز في الحياه في النقش في
النسيج ولكن يخرج عمل فني يمثل شيئا كبيرا
جدا اخذتكم الان في جوله بالتاكيد في هذا
المعرض عدد من الاعمال التي تشاهدونها
الان هي اعمال في ابسط الادوات ولكنها
تمثل اشياء كثيره وتعكس صورا واقعيه لكثير
من الاحداث التي تمثل الجغرافيا التاريخ
الفن الحضاره وعدد ايضا من ثقافات الدول
تركيا وسوريا والسعوديه وايضا عدد كبير
جدا من الدول يسعدني الان تكون معي استاذه
هناء الملي وهي احدى الفنانات في هذا
المعرض اهلا وسهلا فيك في بدايه ساتها
معنا في صباح العربيه وبدايه انا باقي
تتحدثين اليوم عن هذه اللوحه الفنيه
امامنا
هي عباره عن
رفع الاساسيه اللي كانت في ايام زماننا
وتراثنا انا ربع كرديه تركيه سوريه سعوديه
فهذا جزء من عملي همم اللي هو العمل
البحثي عشان ارجع لتراثي منها استعملت
القطن والحرير اللي هو مصبغ يدويا مني من
الاصباغ الطبيعيه اللي هي كانت موجوده في
كردستان سوريا وتركيا والسعوديه طبعا منها
كمان تشوفوا الافلام او النيجاتيف صور
قديمه من الستينات ترجع لي اجدادي طبعا
كمان في
التفاعلي او الفعل التفاعلي من الزوار
اللي كنت ابغى عشان يكون جزء من الذاكره
او جزء من ذاكرتي طبعا لما تمسكوها هي
تعمل اصوات الاصوات تكون عباره عن زي ما
قلت لكم بحث عن الالات الموسيقيه اللي
كانت كمان تستخدم في كل هذه البلدان
طيب اليوم احنا نتكلم عن معارض او كثيره
جدا تقدم هذه الاعمال الفنيه ما شاء الله
هذا هذه اللوحه بشكل كبير جدا تمثل نوع من
الاداء الاوساد العمل الحرف فعلا هو عمل
ادائي وانتم ايضا تمثلون كيف انه شكلتم من
هذه السلسله من الحركات الدقيقه والعمليات
المتعاقبه تدفقات التكرار
تتركز اعمالكم حول الجسد البشري في جوهر
الصناعه الحرفيه حدثنا اكثر عن اللوحات
الموجوده هنا وكيف استطعتم صناعه هذه
اللوحات واا تقاطعات استخصائيه في الاجانب
الممارسات التي تربط الحرف بالجسد البشري
طبعا همم اول شيء هذا المعرض عباره عن ست
فنانات همم منهم السعوديات منهم عربيات
جمعنا همم اللي هو فن النسيج او فن
الحياكه او الاعمال الحرفيه والاعمال
الحرفيه عباره عن الرجوع الى التراث واداء
الاجساد هو جزء منها او جزء
ليش هو جزء كبير منها لانه منها نستخدم
الاعمال او اليد او الجسم او الرجول
للعماله الفنيه ولي التذكار والحنين
والرجوع الى الماضي وكمان انه نعرف الذات
او ذات الشخصي اا فهذه الاعمال الفنيه مو
بس تحكي عن ذات وتستخدم هذه الحرف وكمان
ايضا تستخدم هذا النسيج لتعبر عن اشياء
اكثر من كده ما شاء الله اكثر من فنانه
كثير من الدول حدثيني عن كيف استطعتم
العمل المزيج بين هذه الاعمال التي تشكل
وهذا المعرض وهذه اللوحات الفنيه الكبيره
يعني المنسقه رنا بيروتي من الاردن همم هي
اللي سوت الفكره طبعا والفكره عباره عن
انها تجمع هذول الاشخاص من كل هدول
البلدان معظمهم من همم كمان الجاليري اللي
هي لكم همم لكم مساحه فنيه همم ومعظمهم
اختر من زمان عشان نعبر عن هذه الحرف طبعا
وكمان نعبر عن الفن العصري اللي هو يجمعنا
كلنا همم فلما اخترنا لمن اختنا الاستاذه
رنا هي اللي همم يعني طلعت الفكره وكمان
اختارت الفنانين شكرا لك يا استاذه هنا
اذا سهام نتحدث اليوم عن هذا المعرض
الكبير جدا الذي يحمل العدد من الاعمال
الفنيه همم التي تمثل الاداء الجسدي في
هذه الممارسات وانتقال اليكم في السجن
شكرا جزيلا لكم
صباح العربيه مراسلنا منها الرياض شكرا لك